and now it's time for bomb reviews with
Chester a bomb
tonight's review
up
oh my god the greatest movie I've ever
seen in my life
here's his old man code card although he
wasn't always an old man he used to be
QT - boy I used to be a cute little boy
once when I was born the doctor said I
looked like Bigfoot's testicles so Carl
as a little boy meets a little girl and
she's like a bitch equals Oh big days
really misses the old maid it's less
little girl monkey so he decides there's
only one natural thing to do tiny
million balloons to his chimney and fly
away with this house of course that's
what all people should do wishes and all
the old people into the sky everybody
will be complaining about how slow
midnight hey grandpa can your house go
any slower come on so Carly's flying in
the sky but it turns out there's an
Asian boys down at his door I used to be
an Asian boy scout wasn't that a weird
week so Carla and the boys got her
flying to South America and they come
across a dog who can't talk I wish my
dog could talk but all you can do is
cure cancer when we summon dog comes up
to Carl and says my name is Duncan I
love you and I was like I love that show
Doug Doug Doug Doug Doug Doug victims an
establishment critic doesn't like that
show I bet it's because he has the same
famous what are the characters I'm on to
you mr. mayonnaise Jordan Carl or
looking after this bird and the bird is
like and Carl is like and the boy is
like wow and as I dislike her Perez's
evil dog comes in an evil dog who sounds
like Alvin and the Chipmunks ah hello
Alvin Simon and the fat one
so the birds eat the chip my dog did
he's like bear and Carl is like
and the boy is like wow and the dog is
like true and the chipmunk dog is like
come across this old adventure learning
months and Carly's like I used to watch
you all the time when I was a boy and
months is like for some reason we're
always exactly the same age yeah that
was weird but it turns out once it's
after the bird and months is like
Carly's like and the boy is like wow
and the dog is like learn and show my
dog is like so this is big JC on this
flip and all the characters are there
including the burn the boy the dog world
the trim of dogs my smile a McGee
but then months fools of the house and
the only happy ever after I leave them
the bird the boy the dog the dogs my
smile I tell you this movie inspired me
to die a million balloons to my house
and make you fly which should be too
hard considering I'm living in a bottle
of Pepsi
it's almost paid off this is just a repo
seen me buy some balloons
my Pepsi bottle give me a mile